>> OH, BOY, HELLO, I AM
DANA PERINO, ALONG WITH
JUDGE JEANINE PIRRO,
JESSICA TARLOV, JESSE WATTERS,
AND GREG GUTFELD, IT'S 5:00 IN
NEW YORK CITY, AND THIS IS
"THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
A DRAMATIC MOVE FROM THAT
JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE TODAY, JUST
26 DAYS BEFORE THE MIDTERMS, THE
PANEL VOTING UNANIMOUSLY TO
SUBPOENA FORMER PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP AND IF
PRESIDENT TRUMP DOES NOT APPEAR
OR COMPLY, THE ENTIRE HOUSE
COULD VOTE TO HOLD HIM IN
CONTEMPT OF CONGRESS.
BUT IT'S LIKELY TO BE AN UPHILL
BATTLE, THE SUBPOENA IS SET TO
EXPIRE BY THE END OF THIS
CONGRESSIONAL SESSION AND THAT'S
IN JANUARY.
NEWS COMING AS THE WHITE HOUSE
GETS ROCKED BY THE LAST
INFLATION REPORT BEFORE NOVEMBES
STILL AT RECORD HIGHS, NOT
SHOWING ANY SIGNS OF COMING
DOWN.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAYS AMERICA IS
MAKING PROGRESS.
>> TODAY'S REPORT SHOWS SOME
PROGRESS, OVERALL INFLATION IS
2% OVER THE LAST THREE MONTHS.
THAT IS DOWN FROM 11% OVER THE
PRIOR THREE MONTHS.
THAT'S PROGRESS.
BECAUSE OF MY ECONOMIC PLAN, WE
ARE BETTER POSITIONED THAN ANY
OTHER MAJOR ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
TO WHETHER THE CHALLENGES THAT
COME THROUGH THIS AS A STRONGER
COUNTRY.
IF REPUBLICANS WIN, INFLATION
WILL GET WORSE, IT'S THAT
SIMPLE.
>> Dana: IT'S THAT SIMPLE,
GREG.
SHE WE HAD JANUARY 61ST?
>> Greg: IT WAS A BEAUTIFUL
BACKDROP, VERY INSPIRING FOR
EVERYBODY AND I THINK THAT THEY
SHOULD NAME IT TO THE HUNTER
INFLATION, BECAUSE IT IS ALWAYS
HIGH EVEN WHEN JOE CLAIMS IT
ISN'T.
I AM SO SURPRISED IT WAS
UNANIMOUS VOTE FOR THE SUBPOENA,
AND WHAT A COINCIDENCE THAT THIS
IS HAPPENING JUST A FEW WEEKS
BEFORE THE MIDTERMS.
BUT WHAT ARE THEY TRYING TO DO?
I HAVE A FEELING THAT THEY ARE
SECRETLY TRYING TO REELECT
TRUMP.
BECAUSE THE COMMITTEE IS PROVING
WHAT HE AND MILLIONS OF
SUPPORTERS HAVE ALWAYS SUSPECTED
THAT THE DECK IS STACKED AGAINST
THEM.
THIS IS A KANGAROO COURT, RIGHT?
EVERYBODY HAS THE RIGHT IDEOLOGY
WHETHER IT IS NEVER-TRUMP IS,
IT'S A STACK COMMITTEE WITH
PREORDAINED CONCLUSIONS AND
UNLIMITED TIME AND UNLIMITED
EFFORT PAID FOR BY US, THE
TAXPAYER.
SO WHY WOULDN'T THERE BE THIS
OUTCOME?
EVERYBODY SEES IT AND WHAT THEY
ARE IN DANGER OF DOING IS
CREATING, TURNING TRUMP INTO A
MARTYR, THEY ARE PROVING THE
POINT THAT THEY SWAYED THE
ELECTION.
WE REMEMBER THAT STORY IN "TIME"
MAGAZINE WHERE THEY BOASTED
ABOUT THE END OF KABUL, THE
MEDIA, THE DEMOCRATS, THE TECH
COMPANIES, THIS JUST REMINDS YOU
THEY ARE HUNTING TRUMP AND TRUMP
SUPPORTERS.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE THINK
THAT RON DeSANTIS IS A BETTER
CHOICE, A YOUNGER SMOOTHER, MORE
SOPHISTICATED CANDIDATE, BUT YOU
CAN HAVE PEOPLE THAT SAY, SCREW
IT, I WILL VOTE FOR TRUMP,
BECAUSE THESE PEOPLE ARE IDIOTS
AND THIS IS A SCAM.
THEY ARE MURDERING HIM.
>> Dana: DO YOU WANT TO
COMMENT ON JANUARY 6, INFLATION?
DEALER'S CHOICE.
>> Jesse: I AM IMPRESSED WITH
THE DEMOCRATS AND I DON'T ALWAYS
SAY THAT, BUT THEY ARE SO
DEVIOUS, THEY PLOT, THEY PLAN,
THEY DECEIVE.
THEY KNEW THIS PRINCE WAS GOING
TO PRINT HOT TODAY ON INFLATION,
AND THEY TIMED IT PERFECTLY.
BECAUSE IT'S PROBABLY GOING TO
BLOW OUT THE INFLATION LEAD ON
THE NIGHTLY NEWS CHANNELS, AND
IT IS MAY BE A ONE-DAY THING,
BUT THEY GOT WHAT THEY WANTED.
>> Greg: THEY DID IT HERE.
>> Jesse: THEY DID IT HERE, IT
TAKES IT OUT OF THE NUMBER THAT
DROPPED, AND I SOMETIMES WISH
THAT THE REPUBLICANS COULD BE AS
CRAFTY AS THIS.
THEY WERE PRETTY CRAFTY WITH THE
FIGURES, BUT THEY HAVE TO
COUNTER PUNCH.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT EVERYONE
IS LOSING MONEY UNDER JOE BIDEN,
LOSING IT FROM THEIR PAYCHECKS,
LOSING IT FROM THE STOCK MARKET,
PEOPLE ARE LOSING THEIR LIVES,
PEOPLE ARE LOSING THE BORDER,
LITTLE KIDS ARE LOSING THEIR
GENDER, BECAUSE I GET STUFFED IN
CLASSROOMS WITH GROOMING
TEACHERS.
THAT IS NOTHING TO DO TODAY WITH
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC IS EXPERIENCING.
THIS TRUMP THING DOES NOT AFFECT
ANYBODY, AND THE DEMOCRATS KNOW
THAT, BUT THEY DON'T WANT TO
SOLVE PROBLEMS THEY HAVE
CREATED, THEY WANT TO DISTRACT
YOU SO THAT YOU DON'T THINK AS
MUCH ABOUT ALL OF THE PROBLEMS.
THAT THEY HAVE CREATED, THEY ARE
NOT ABOUT THE PEOPLE, THEY ARE
ABOUT THE POWER AND THAT'S WHY
THEY DID TO THE SAUDIS WHAT THEY
IMPEACHED TRUMP FOUR, THEY SAID
I'M GOING TO WITHHOLD MILITARY
AID IT TO AN ALLY EXCHANGE FOR A
POLITICAL FAVOR, WHAT'S A FAVOR?
OH, GOING TO PUT IN MORE BEFORE
THE MIDTERMS, THEY ARE ACTUALLY
BLATANTLY ANNOUNCING THE
SHAKEDOWN, THE QUID PRO QUO, BUT
NO ONE CARES, NO ONE CARES AT
ALL.
IT IS FUNNY, BECAUSE I WOULD
ACTUALLY GIVE THEM --
IF THEY WANT TO INVESTIGATE AND
LOOK BACK AT STUFF, LET'S DO IT,
BUT THEY ONLY WANT TO LOOK BACK
AT JANUARY 6.
NOT AT THE ORIGIN OF COVID, THEY
DON'T WANT TO LOOK BACK TO WHERE
ALL THE MONEY WENT THAT WE GAVE
THE TEACHERS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO LOOK AT THE
AFGHAN DEBACLE, THEY DON'T WANT
TO LOOK AT HUNTER'S LAPTOP, THEY
DON'T WANT TO KNOW ANYTHING THAT
HAPPENED YESTERDAY AS LONG AS IT
IS JANUARY 6TH.
>> Dana: ON THE LEGAL SIDE,
THE SUBPOENA, ENFORCEABLE,
NONENFORCEABLE?
>> Judge Jeanine: AT SOME
POINT IT WILL BE ENFORCEABLE,
BUT IT WILL BE DELAYED AND
DELAYED ON THE REPUBLICANS WILL
WIN THE HOUSE AND THAT WILL BE
THE END OF IT.
THIS IS TIMED PERFECTLY FOR
TODAY WHEN THEY GOT THE NUMBERS
TODAY AND I HAVE TO TELL YOU, I
MEAN, I HEARD YOUR INTERVIEW
WITH JARED BERNSTEIN THIS
MORNING.
>> Dana: ARE YOU PULLING YOUR
HAIR OUT?
>> Judge Jeanine: I WAS
PULLING MY HAIR OUT AND TRY NOT
TO YELL AT THE TELEVISION,
BECAUSE EVERY QUESTION YOU ASKED
HIM COMING HIS HEAD WITH THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT, YOU
KNOW, THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS PUT
IN PLACE THAT IS REDUCING
INFLATION, AND IT COULD NOT HELP
BUT THINK THAT THE PRESIDENT
HIMSELF PRETTY MUCH ADMITTED
THAT IT DOES NOT REDUCE
INFLATION WHEN HE SAID IN
MARYLAND, HE SAID WE PASSED THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT, WHICH
DOES NOT MATTER TO A WHOLE LOT
OF PEOPLE, WHERE BASICALLY
ADMITTING THAT IT DOES NOT
REDUCE INFLATION, AND WE SAVED
EVERYTHING WITH THE STRATEGIC
PETROLEUM RESERVE, WE DUMPED ALL
OF THAT OIL ONTO THE WORLD
MARKET, SO THAT CHINA COULD BUY
IT.
IT'S LIKE IT'S AMAZING WHAT IS
HAPPENING AND HOW THEY TRIED TO
SPIN IT, BUT YOU HAVE TO GIVE
THEM CREDIT, IT IS POLITICS.
THAT'S WHAT IT IS.
THIS THING WITH THE SUBPOENA IS
MEANINGLESS, I'M SURE THAT HE
COULD CARE LESS ABOUT IT.
HE HAS A LOT OF ISSUES RIGHT
NOW.
HE HAS GEORGIA GOING ON,
LETITIA JAMES, THE
NEW YORK STATE ATTORNEY GENERAL,
HE HAS THE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS,
SO THIS IS JUST PARADING AROUND
BY PEOPLE IN CONGRESS.
IT IS THE SAME GROUP, YOU KNOW?
NO REPUBLICANS OTHER THAN LIZ
CHENEY AND WHAT'S HIS NAME?
CRYER.
ADAM KINZINGER.
HE IS NOT WORRIED ABOUT IT, I'M
NOT WORRIED ABOUT IT, AND I
DON'T THINK THAT THIS IS GOING
TO WORK WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WHO KNOW THAT GAS IS GOING UP,
FOOD IS GOING UP, THEY CAN
AFFORD WHAT THEY USE TO AFFORD,
AND THEY HAVE THREE WEEKS TO
WATCH THE PRICES GO UP.
>> Dana: AND ALSO HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY, SO YOUR RENT OR
NOW YOUR MORTGAGE AT 6.9%
INTEREST RATE.
JESSICA, I WILL GIVE YOU THE
FLOOR FOR THE LAST WORD.
>> Jessica: THANK YOU, SO TO
THE POINT ABOUT THE DECK IS
STACKED AGAINST THEM, THESE ARE
ALL ESSENTIALLY DEMOCRATS AS
REPUBLICANS ARE RHINOS OR
ANTI--TRUMP-E.R.ES, THEY
REJECTED HIS PROPOSALS AND
COULD'VE PUT MORE ON, AND
DONALD TRUMP IS CRITICIZED FOR
THAT.
SO LET'S BE CLEAR ABOUT IT.
I NEVER SAID THAT JANUARY 6 WILL
AFFECT PEOPLE'S VOTES.
YOU HAVE A BAKED AND FEELING
ABOUT WHAT YOU THINK ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP, IF YOU THOUGHT THE
TWO IMPEACHMENTS BEFORE THIS
WERE A GOOD IDEA AND THEY WERE
IMPORTANT TO DO, THEN YOU THINK
JANUARY 6TH IS AN IMPORTANT
THING TO UNCOVER WHAT HAPPENED
THAT DAY AND WE WILL SEE IF THEY
MAKE CRIMINAL REFERRALS TO THE
DOJ OR NOT.
THEY MIGHT NOT DO IT.
IN TERMS OF THE INFLATION
NUMBER, GAS, OR A BLOCK CHANGED,
BECAUSE OF THIS AND IT HAPPENS
ALL ACROSS THE NEWS, BUT THAT
DOES NOT MEAN THAT THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC HAS LOST SIGHT OF HOW
THEIR DAY WENT, HOW MUCH THEIR
DRUGS COST, HOW THEIR GAS TANK
COSTS, ET CETERA, AND WHAT HAS
BEEN INTERESTING TO LOOK AT IS
INFLATION HAS STAYED, OR
INFLATION IN THE ECONOMY HAS A
NUMBER ONE ISSUE, PERIOD, END OF
STORY, BUT WHAT IS TAKING US IS
JOE BIDEN'S PERSONAL APPROVAL
MEMBERS AND I DID NOT EXPECT TO
SEE THAT, SO IT'S AT 45%, THAT'S
ACTUALLY PRETTY GOOD.
HEADING INTO A MIDTERM WHEN
>> Greg: THAT MET GOOD JOB.
>> Jessica: ARE YOU ARE DOING
A BAD JOB.
>> Dana: OH, THAT'S A GOOD
LAST WORD.
COMING UP --
A [LAUGHTER]
COMING UP, ENDING ON THE H